the 14 years I've been doing the NFL
Network some of the most enjoyable
assignments I did were a couple of years
at Jon Gruden was with the NFL Network
before he left us for Monday Night
Football and the greener pastures of
that property and here from Monday Night
Football which will be broadcasting the
week 10 finale between the Panthers and
the Miami Dolphins is Jon Gruden back
back here on the Rich Eisen show how you
been John hey how's it going I'm doing
great
let's get jump right into this headfirst
do you think Thursday Night Football is
dangerous for players John yeah I do
think it is dangerous I think the old
format of having a Thanksgiving Day
Thursday game was great but I do think
especially early in the season with free
agency the way these teams practice now
to play two games in the first week of
the season is crazy I think it's really
compromising to the visiting team
because they have to travel and it
impacts their preparation both teams
clearly have no chance to physically and
mentally get ready for a game every
Thursday every week I don't like it much
and I really don't like the uniforms
either I said no I'm more into tradition
I had to watch that game last night in
black and white my eyeballs hurt I was
getting vertigo watching the Seattle you
sure that wasn't because Russell Wilson
was pure wetting around and making great
plays with his arms in his legs again I
might have been part of it how do you
think how long conservative Seattle
survive essentially with an offense that
relies on everything going through their
quarterback who leads the team in
rushing it's tough I mean it is tough
they're a one-dimensional team they have
to get every inch they make with Russell
Wilson creating right now it's
unfortunate you know Jimmy Graham is a
great receiver but he's a receiving
tight end they really struggle to run
block and it's hard to believe because
when you think Seattle you think great
defense you think Marshawn Lynch and you
think of a great running game but that
has not been the case the last couple
seasons and I worry about Wilson he is
he is playing the game
like any any quarterback I've seen in
some time Jon Gruden here on the Rich
Eisen show and they're all looking up at
the Los Angeles Rams right now John and
we've had Sean McVeigh in studio a
couple of times he comes straight from
the staff or your brother and I gotta
tell you he sounds a lot like you I mean
he's got the same cadence the same
Gruden cadence and he is out here just
rat radically improved this offense what
has he done you know you're a guy who
could who knows the X's and O's and
certainly knows where he where McVeigh
is coming from what has he done to
improve everything as fast as he has
well first he's brought a very good
system that has has worked for a lot of
years he comes from a football royalty
his grandfather John McVay help build
the San Francisco 49ers in their glory
years and you know he comes from great
stock he's an excellent teacher
he's a very good communicator and you
got to give him credit risks he's hired
an excellent staff it all starts there
you have to hire the right coaches he
gets Wade Phillips who just so happens
to be a free agent perhaps he got a
little bit lucky because Wade was let go
at Denver but he got an excellent
veteran defensive coordinator he brought
in Aaron Cromer a good offensive line
coach Greg Olson who worked with Shaun
in Tampa coaching a quarterbacks he
acquired a good coaching staff that's
where it all starts and they have made
over this roster they brought in Andrew
Whitworth who really is part of the
demise of the Bengals and the uprise of
the Rams he has solidified them at left
tackle where they have been a train
wreck the last three or four years and
he's brought toughness they're the only
team in a league that has the same five
starting offensive lineman for the first
half of the season they've been lucky
that way too and it's allowed them to
feature Todd Gurley and they went out
and brought in some really good players
don't forget Sammy Watkins wasn't there
last year woods wasn't there Evert the
tight end wasn't there and Jared Goff
has really taken off under Shaun McVeigh
it's a credit to him so when it all
comes down to it though everyone's
looking up at the eight and one Eagles
are they the best team that you've
personally eyeballed so far this season
John yeah they're the best team I've
seen the quarterback is the real
ille you can talk about Brady and all
the other great quarterbacks right now
but in the first half of the season
Carson Wentz has lit it up and he has
made some unbelievable Scramble plays
some audibles at the line of scrimmage
he can run any play that you can think
of and they have added some players you
know getting a je to go with LeGarrette
want is impressive they're receiving
corps went over a huge makeover getting
Torrey Smith and Alshon Jeffery and you
can say one thing about Philadelphia
they will rush the passer and they will
hit your quarterback in when you get a
lead they can protect it with that pass
rush so you think they survive the NFC
when it's all said and done what do you
think I don't know you know this league
right now there's a couple injuries here
a couple injuries there that can really
impact you if they stay healthy I would
I would bet on Philadelphia to be the
representative of the NFC this year you
bet hmm
and then who's the best team in the AFC
do you think right now John you know I
don't know yet I think there's still
some teams that are that are hiding in
the rough I still want to see more from
the Patriots defense if they can pick it
up on that side of the ball hard to bet
against Brady and Belichick but there's
a couple other teams that are that are a
little bit interesting in that that
division I can't figure out Kansas City
can their pass rush come around can they
get opportunistic on defense like they
have in years past I don't know and
we'll have to wait and see I still think
there might be a couple teams that are
that are sleeping along like the
Tennessee Titans for some reason I have
a strong feeling about Marcus Mariota in
it Titans what about the Jaguars what do
you think about that I mean they have
the defense falling out they have Jalen
Ramsey who's who's making his presence
known and felt as we saw last week for
net despite getting disciplined they won
without him right there now he comes
back it all is about the quarterback
there one would think John yes okay I
think so you know I was disappointed to
see fournette miss a game as a rookie
you know when you're a rookie you're
supposed to be toeing the line pretty
good I was really disappointed in that
but you're right the Jaguar defense is
as good as there is in football I saw
what they did to the Pittsburgh Steelers
in Pittsburgh and everybody talks about
Ramsey rightfully so but the guy on the
other side
J my boy yeh is pretty good too man and
they can rush the passer class Campbell
has really packed a lot of punch into
that pass rush Jon Gruden few more
minutes here with Jon Gruden from the
worldwide leader in sports and Monday
Night Football here on the Rich Eisen
show can you went around Jameis Winston
the National Football League Jon Gruden
yeah you can went around him he's he won
nine games last year in his second year
he's obviously getting his eyes open to
how hard it is in the NFL and hopefully
it's a lesson for him and a lot of young
players out there this this is a short
trip from the penthouse to the outhouse
and from the outhouse to the penthouse
you can ask the Rams you can ask the
Jaguars they have gone up in this league
in a rapid pace and there have been
teams that have fallen out of the sky as
well
I remember we want a Super Bowl one year
and I'm working at the FFC a the next oh
you got to bring consistency and a
tremendous work ethic and be real
careful about everything you do because
the football gods are watching the FFC a
for those who are potentially unfamiliar
you want to describe what that stands
for John well that's a fired Football
Coaches Association I'll send you a hat
rich please we'll all we do really is we
just study football we've got a little
laboratory down here guys should come
from around the country and we study
different situations and plays and
personnel and we also try to raise money
and we give it back to high school and
youth sports because a lot of people are
beating up the game right now and it
really bothers me and followers a lot of
people so we're trying to save high
school football in youth football so
kids can play in the future and you
still have that spot behind a Publix
down there in Tampa upgraded you got to
come down I've upgraded I got my own
building now and I even got a bedroom
here I got a bedroom I added a shower so
if I want to stay here all night
watching the Miami Dolphin tape I can do
that I'm a great dude you know that no I
know because sometimes hygiene can get
lost in that coaching world careful you
still you're still a human being when it
all comes down to it one wasn't pretty
when was the last time you got a call to
say I want you to be my coach if you're
up for it when was the last time you got
that phone call
well I don't know you know it's it's in
your blood you get you get some people
call them maybe to see if you're
interested in coaching again and maybe
if you can help recommend a couple guys
I'm pretty much involved with every
level of football every day of the week
so I try to help if I can if I can and
you know one of these days who knows
rich you know one of these days you
never know but I'm just trying to hang
on to the job I have as you know I don't
have Aaron seed contract no stop you're
great at it but the whole point is is
that is that when you you know people
are wondering if there is that scenario
out there for you do you have it in your
mind or is it just one of those things
that's just gonna hit you say maybe this
is the one John you know what I have
talked to people in years past and I
plan on just keeping my options open you
know I'm I'm uh like I said I'm 54 years
old now and I'm really happy doing what
I'm doing I'm with great people I think
we have a really good team and I look
forward to going and traveling with the
team of Monday Night Football on our
cruise so I'm gonna just keep doing what
I'm doing if something comes along down
the road we'll take a look at it yeah I
know it's into bloody I mean I see it
Mariucci John who's as you know out of
coaching for a while
he's got the empty nest now he loves
being a granddad he loves being around
for everything and then he gets into a
stadium and he gets his hands on his
knees and he starts slapping at the
officials and talking of coaches he just
I see it I see a first I saw last night
in Arizona it's tough man you know it's
tough especially when you get around
these players you know you get around I
mean sometimes you sit there and you got
more if I could help this kid I wish I
could try to help him I wish I could do
something to make a difference but at
the same time I look at my job that way
in broadcasting I get to be a part of QB
camp with all the young quarterbacks I
feel like I'm helping them a little bit
I do get a chance to prepare every week
and hopefully do a decent job as Foreman
are our viewers out there on two teams
that we have for Monday Night Football
and like I said here at the FFC a I host
a lot of coaches I host a lot of players
last one what's the spread like at the
FFC a now John come on now what's the
spread long here's I got an astroturf
floor I got the biggest TV monitor
you've ever seen Eisen I mean this thing
is so big I watch behind me I got a TV I
can
watch you on NFL Network around your 40
I got tape stacked on every wall I got
my own kitchen upstairs I got a workout
room and I got a bedroom I got two or
three other rooms with coaching stations
set up where coaches can come in and
study tape so I don't drive them crazy
okay
hey you'd love it man I got a room also
filled with gear I got hats t-shirts I
got all kind of gear we give away and
it's it's quite a place and then John
I'm in man I mean you know I've been do
you charge rent do you charge rent for I
don't everything is free I pay the rent
and that's why I try to you know I try
to save my money so I can pay the bills
brother but hey I appreciate you risk
I'm I see a man you're upbeat you're
positive you love football and just
remember we got a we got to save this
game and keep the game strong but I
really really enjoy watching listening
to you and thanks for having me on the
broadcast right back it right back at
you John thanks for calling in we'll
chat soon okay brother take care you got
at Jon Gruden the one and only the mold
broken of the worldwide leader in sports
Monday Night Football and the FFC a
which sounds like he's got a palace
sounds like it the Jon Mahal for more
Rich Eisen show tuned to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Rich Eisen show app